this is terry's a ringtailed lemur
he is quite the character
of the hundred or so species of lemurs
in madagascar the ring-tailed lemur is
easily the most iconic because of its
black and white ringed tail
they're mostly vegetarian feeding on
fruit leaves flowers bark and the
occasional insect or lizard that they
find in the desert scrub land and woods
of southwestern madagascar
they're more social than most lemurs
with as many as 24 members in a group
when traveling together they keep their
tails raised in the air like flags in
order to make sure no one gets lost
unfortunately
they have to travel farther to find
suitable habitats the habitats they
prefer to call home are being rapidly
destroyed by expanding farmland
overgrazing from livestock and charcoal
harvesting
while conservationists battle for the
lima survival there's hope
ring-tailed lemurs breed very
successfully in captivity and there are
over 1 000 individuals at 140 zoos
around the world
this is the ringtad lima